I pledge that I will serve you with
integrity and humility
and I will work day in day out to
deliver for the British people the UK
has a new prime minister Rishi sunak a
former investment banker takes over at a
time of big financial and economic
challenges what's unusual is that less
than two months ago sunak actually lost
an election within his party to get the
job but his rival is trust resigned I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
and only a few years after starting in
politics sunak became the first person
of color to lead the United Kingdom
here's a look at how he rose through the
ranks of the conservative party
today I have the enormous privilege of
standing here as a member of parliament
sunak made his debut in Parliament in
2015 putting a sense of humor on display
as a lawmaker representing a county in
northern England and although I am not
from Yorkshire they were immensely
relieved to learn that I was not from
Lancashire either
son of a pharmacist and a doctor of
Indian descent he was an early supporter
of brexit and one on the whole Junior
ministerial roles but his career really
took off when he got the second most
important job in Boris Johnson's
government sunac who holds an MBA from
Stanford and has worked for Goldman
Sachs among other places became the UK's
treasury Chief how do you feel about
taking over these circumstances
delighted to be appointed lots to get on
with and he immediately came into the
spotlight overseeing the government's
response to the covid-19 pandemic I can
announce today an unprecedented package
of government-backed and guaranteed
loans to support business to get through
this he announced a large spending
program when I say large 330 billion
pounds to help businesses pay wages to
millions of people who couldn't work
during the pandemic
in early 2022 as his boss faced a series
of scandals Rishi sunak resigned as
treasury Chief and soon after Johnson
himself stepped down sunak made an
announcement I'm standing to be the next
leader of the conservative party and
your prime minister sunac raced against
truss whose plans he called fairy tale
economics in televised debates he
stressed that the priority should be to
keep inflation and interest rates under
control yeah your plans would mean the
interest rates would have to go up to
around seven percent so just think what
that means for all of your mortgages he
lost that race but won the argument
after truss's plans caused havoc on
financial markets now trust is out and
he's won the UK Premiership in one of
the more spectacular I Told You So
moments in modern politics
so what challenges does he inherit from
his predecessors the economy will be one
big thing on his agenda there's a
looming recession in the UK in high
inflation which creates a double whammy
for ordinary people sunak who is
advocated for spending cuts has also
been widely criticized by the British
press and public as a former hedge fund
manager who is married to the daughter
of one of India's richest men he has
sometimes been seen as out of touch with
the people's economic reality
[Music]